okay I'm sure many of you have already
seen this because it was rather widely
announced but the open AI team has
announced a new model that produces
pictures instead of text so as you can
see right here on the Left you'll always
see like a half a picture and on the
right is the ground truth so they took
this picture
they simply cut the bottom half right
here and then they let the model sort of
imagine what they cut away and what it
comes up with is pretty cool I have to
say like look at the birds like this is
just awesome but the special thing about
this isn't that it simply completes
pictures the special thing about it is
it does it one pixel by pixel so
basically it goes at this pixel right
here and asks ok what's that pixel and
then what's that pixel and then what's
that pixel and so on so it is basically
a like a language model but four pixels
in that it goes over the images in order
basically like this or like always from
left to right left to right left to
right and it has no clue of the spatial
relations between the pixels it needs to
learn that by itself as opposed to a
convolutional neural network which is
specifically designed such that if you
want to predict this pixel right here
then it's specifically designed to say
ok the most important information is
probably around that pixel and then some
like other important information is
while around that pixel so cnn's are
built with this in mind
whereas this model right here which is
also known as image GPT isn't doesn't
have any of that it's simply a
transformer model that goes over these
pixels one by one and we'll see how
that's done there are some more examples
right here particularly cool is the cat
and you see that there is the beginning
of this little white thing
here which is this card and the
completions of the model yes very
interesting the model can of course as a
language model can also sample by itself
just random images you sample them once
through and this is what it comes up
with so these are pretty good quality
images for a model that just produces
one pixel by one pixel now this idea of
one pixel by pixel isn't new this has
been around before but the investigation
here is basically how much can we how
far can we push these generative models
for pre-training hi there this is
Yannick from post-production I've
realized that I've forgotten to even
read the name of the paper so it's
called generative pre-training from
pixels by March and Alec Radford round
child jeff whoo he won't jus profile a
dairy wall David Lewin and Ilya
sutskever and since Henry AI labs has
already made a video on this this video
is going to be more of kind of a rumble
rant about what I find interesting about
the paper and some thoughts about it
rather than like a classic explanation I
hope you still enjoy that so what you
saw on the right wasn't even though this
isn't the final result the supposed
result this is simply the pre-training
task it's fun to look at it but the
actual object objective of the paper is
the following
what if we train we pre train on a large
data set to generate work good images
like these or we to complete images like
these and then we fine-tune on a
classification task and the answer is
here they say on C 410 we achieve 60
96.3%
accuracy with a linear probe
outperforming a super wide supervised
the wide ResNet and the 99
cent accuracy with full fine tuning
matching the top supervisor pre-trained
models an even larger model trained on a
mixture of imagenet and web images is
competitive with self supervised
benchmarks on image net achieving 72 top
one accuracy on a linear probe of our
features so the goal here is that you
have a data set that you want to trend
like train a classifier on so usually
you have a data set and the data set has
images and you put them through like a
convolutional neural network and then
you have to classify the image into one
of I don't know how many classes on C
for ten that's ten classes on image and
it's a thousand and the data set is
these images together with these labels
now the idea of pre training is that you
some where have a bigger data set that
is sort of similar to the small data set
but it's similar enough such that the
network could learn something so what
you want to do first is your first one
it take the large data set terrain this
network right here and then in a second
step fine-tune the network on this
smaller data set and you sort of hope
that what you learned from the large
data set right here transfers over a
little bit of knowledge you already have
a little bit of knowledge and you can
make better use of the data that you
have right here now the question is how
do you do this pre training and of
course this has a long tradition well
long for maybe two or three years right
now in the language community where
people they pre trained these large
models like we've just seen GP t3 or
Bert was one of them they pre trained
these large Transformer models on text
and then to fine-tune them on
classification tasks for text and that's
what this paper is doing right here they
pre trained a transformer that is a GPT
to scale model they pre train it on
image generation
and then they fine-tune it or transfer
learn it to classification tasks and the
point of the papers to say that like in
text data in text data we have made
pretty good pretty good experiences with
doing this with pre-training a
generative model and then fine-tuning on
a classification task while so far in
images all we've ever done is we've
pre-trained this pre training task he
usually is a classification task or like
a self supervised task with a
contrastive loss or something like this
what they're doing new is the generative
modeling in the pre as a pre training
and again this isn't like entirely new
but they show that if you throw a lot of
computers at it and lots of data and a
big model then that can work equally
well to these self supervised tasks so
their model as I said is pretty pretty
simple they take an image and they
unrolled the image now an fully unrolled
image on let's say image net has 224
squared pixels and that times three
right because you have three color
channels that's too large even for an
open a supercomputer so what they do is
first they down scale the image so they
down scale it's not as drastic as here
where you just get a three by three
image but they do down scale it to like
a 32 by 32 or a 64 by 64 then they
unroll it which simply means they go
through the image like this and make a
sequence out of it because their models
are naturally made for text sequences
they simply put the image into a text
sequence they further simplify this by
reducing the three colour channels to a
single one so they have their own color
representation and basically yeah they
reduce the three colour channels to one
channel that simply indexes the color in
their color representation and they say
still pretty good it's pretty faithful
so ultimately they end up with like 32
squared length representation of their
image and then they do one of two things
they either do auto regressive
generative pre-training which is the
sort of GPT - style pre-training and the
the idea here is that you always want to
predict the next pixel of a sequence so
you can see right here that's the
sequence that you are sorry that's the
sequence that you input and you always
want to predict what is the next pixel
and in this case you've seen you see
that we've already predicted everything
here we've already predicted everything
up to this red pixel so you want to know
what's this next pixel this thing right
here what's this going to be and the
diagram here basically shows you how the
attention flow so every position in this
transformer and if you don't know what a
transformer is I haven't made a video
about attention is all you need where
these are explained but briefly every
position here can sort of send
information can send information only in
one direction as to so you train all of
these in parallel and when you predict
this pixel right here
you only want information from whatever
it was before that pixel otherwise the
model could cheat right otherwise the
model could simply learn to copy over
the value but the attention pattern here
is simply to show you that this is auto
regressive and it's in one direction so
you always want to predict the next
pixel and then from all of this you want
to predict the next pixel and from all
of this you want to predict the next
pixel this is in contrast to this
objective here that comes from Bert and
I've also made a video on Bert what you
do in Bert is you simply take that image
and you cross a block out two of the
pixels or many of the pixels and you
simply ask your network to reconstruct
those
pixels okay and now you can see the
attention flows in all direction birth
the B stands actually for a
bi-directional so this is the contrast
to the autoregressive pre training
framework now the these two things have
been applied in text both the
autoregressive is usually it's easier to
actually make it produce something like
we saw producing these images because
you can always just predict the next
pixel and then the next and then the
next and then the next
whereas in Beart it's a bit more unclear
how you would produce things in a
consistent manner because the
predictions of these two pixels right
here they are independent it's one
forward pass and then both of these are
predicted but other papers have tried to
solve this like this not excel net I
forget I forget its name it's something
with an X and yeah but but these are the
two objectives they look at and it turns
out they sort of trade off a bit they
work equally well or a bit better and a
bit worse depending on the task so once
they have done this so they simply feed
images and you will notice that you
don't need any labels for this so what
you'll do is simply input an image and
then simply take away half of it like
this and then predict that pixel and
then you want to predict that pixel and
then you want to predict that pixel
right that's all like you do with text
and invert you simply input an image
cross out pixels and then predict them
so you don't need labels for this and
that's why you can do it with this big
data set and you can do it in an
unsupervised fashion so you can just
crawl the internet for four images and
just feed this in into there and it will
sort of learn to produce these images
now the question is if you produce if
you learn to produce these images does
that help you for classification and
there they have two methods of of
assessing this the bottom one here is
the fine-tuning method where you simply
so this is supposed to be the
representation you learn in the
different layers of the network so this
is supposed to be this thing right here
what you'll do is you'll simply
fine-tune that means you on top of this
representation you add a classification
head that has two outputs cat or dog and
you train this entire network on your
small data set that we discussed before
so you train the entire network all of
the parameters this is called fine
tuning in contrast to that what you can
do is you can simply and this is the
easy way you can simply add this
classification head with two outputs and
then only train this classification head
and that is won't perform as well but it
gives you sort of a better idea of how
good is the representation that this
network right here learned and on top of
that so if you spin this idea further
you can actually go and do this at any
intermediate layer right here so you can
forward propagate until layer two right
here and then here you add your
classification head into the two into
the two classes and you only train the
classification head that being said you
can also do this with fine tuning but in
this case this is called a linear probe
and it is often used to assess how good
the a representation in intermediate
layers is whereas what it actually does
is assessing how linearly classifiable a
representation is which isn't the same
as how useful or how informative but it
is one way to to assess these things
okay so these are the two things they
assess alright so for as for data sets
for C 410 they use like C for 10 and c
for 100 as data sets and the STL 10 and
there you have to keep in mind the pre
training is done on imagenet for those
so that you pre train on imagenet
without the labels and then you transfer
learn or fine tune or
or linear probe on these small data sets
whereas later we're going to look at
image net and they're the pre-training
as I understand it is done on image net
itself but also a wider collection of a
hundred million or so images from the
web from the internet okay so as you can
see right here this is what happens if
you do this linear probing and you can
see it works pretty well so you get like
a ninety-five ninety-six percent
accuracy with linear probes this is very
powerful so it's not easy to get 96
percent on C for ten I mean current
state of the art is like ninety nine
percent but still 96 percent is pretty
good and this is the so the entire
network there is this big giant network
that you input your image into and then
there is this one linear layer that does
the classification and all of this right
here has not been trained with
classification in mind it simply has
been trained to reproduce images it
hasn't even been trained on C for ten as
far as I understand has been trained on
image net so the the this is to stress
how cool or how significant this result
is basically that just a linear probe on
top of that will give you such a good
accuracy and the second thing that is
obvious right here is this bottom axis
is the layer so this is the layer where
they attach the linear probe and usually
if you pre train a network with a
classification task in mind so you pre
train it with the labels or maybe even
without the labels in a self supervised
the way or something like this usually
the last layer has the best
representation for classification but
here the special thing is that the
intermediate layers in the middle have
the best representation you can see that
representation quality in terms of
linear probing falls off as they sort of
it falls off as they go into higher
layers and this is consistent across the
datasets as you can see and the the idea
here is or the way they interpret it is
that if you have an image right here
Dada Dada Dada
and they you've blocked part of it
so you've blocked this and this wrong
way around this
so you've generated everything and now
your task is to predict the next pixel
right so you're you train to predict
this next pixel right here and the idea
is that as you put the image through the
network what it will do is sort of since
the first layers they're going to be if
you're going to be similar to a CNN
they're going to be doing some low level
of feature transformation thing right
but also the last layers they're going
to really care about what's the exact
pixel that goes here right since it's
their job to to do that they're going to
care what color does it need to have you
know what exact luminosity and so on how
does it fit in with the previous pixels
and so on where as so that's that's also
good but it's not just low level
information and consistency with other
pixels or something like this at some
point if you want to generate consistent
images and we saw that this model can
generate consistent images at some point
there needs to be some kind of a notion
of the global information in the picture
right such because the images are
consistent throughout so there needs to
be some some notion of what is in that
image as a whole and that's the exact
information that we need for
classification and the only way that
could actually be is here in the middle
since you know that's the place so the
hypothesis is that the these models
somehow learn a higher-level
representation of global information
somewhere in the middle before they then
specify that information again down to
predict the actual pixel and that's why
the best representations for
classification are in the middle so this
is one of the this is actually the
interesting finding or one of the
interesting findings of this paper means
cool that they can reach a good accuracy
but to recognize that maybe in these
these generative models they have some
intermediate stage where they represent
the global information and that will
actually make the best representation
okay the second cool thing right here is
that you can see they have different
sizes of models so the IGP TL I believe
is something like sixty layers then this
is like 48 layers and this is 32 layers
we don't really so these are on the
olive on the scale of GPT to either a
little bigger or a little smaller it's
not like a GPT three scale where you
need a ginormous supercomputer though
they do do a lot of computation but it
this still sort of fits within hardware
of a standard size and not like exascale
what's interesting right here is that
you can see the larger models they reach
a lower validation loss so here is the
validation loss larger model if you
train them on so these checkpoints here
are always after the same amount of
steps the larger models do reach a lower
validation loss right here as you can
see so this is the large this is the
medium this is the small and also you
can see that on this axis is the linear
probe accuracy so this is whenever you
you go and you find the best
intermediate layer for linear probing
you probe it and you record the accuracy
so you can see a general trend
as your validation loss goes down the
linear probe accuracy goes up so there
is a connection like it is in text
models and text models there's a
connection of the perplexity of your
language model and the quality that of
the representation you get for
downstream tasks in this model it seems
to be the exact same thing there is a
connection between reaching lower
validation laws and reaching a higher
performance on classification so that's
one interesting thing the general trend
- up to the upper right corner the other
interesting and even arguably even more
interesting thing is that if you look at
the same validation loss so at this
point all of these models have the same
validation all's yet still the bigger
model is better right you can see right
here the bigger model outperforms the
smaller model even though they have the
same validation loss on the image
modeling task and this is also something
that openly I in their in their text
papers has stressed that the larger
models they seem to be somehow more
capable of forming good representations
even you know even if they have the same
loss so again this this could just be
sort of a training data
remember training data remembering thing
and when I set that in GPT three I
didn't actually mean explicit
remembering of training data I meant a
kind of a fuzzy remembering of training
data of I formulate that in the in the
comments but I I feel a lot of people
have misunderstood me there
here I think it's a much harder harder
to estimate what's going on also since
image pixels humans don't have a super
good model of an on image pixels in
their head as we have about text as you
can see if you then fine tune so for now
we've just do linear probing if you
fine-tune these architectures then you
reach like a 99% accuracy on C for ten
which is on par with the best models
that we have so G pipe is supervised pre
trained on imagenet but also I guess
uses a bunch of data element ation while
these image GPT it uses minimal data
augmentation I think they simply random
crop a little bit and that's about it so
they also experiment around with this
Bert objective so until now this was all
the this was all this autoregressive
objective and I feel the open hi people
are a bit more of a fan of the
autoregressive objective just given what
they've done so far in their papers and
you can see here comparison of the two
objectives on C for 10 and on image net
again C for 10 is pre trained with image
net and image net itself is pre trained
with like a larger collection of images
from the web all the pre training is
done without labels now the blue is what
you can reach with a linear probe and
the orange is then on top of that what
you can reach by fine-tuning okay so no
linear profile tuning oh I have to say
that the fine tuning is always done at
the end so even though the linear probe
even though the linear probe can be
attached anywhere in between and it's
often useful to do that as we saw
because the in between layers are the
best
they say they tried fine-tuning also in
from in between but it always worked out
best
whenever you fine-tune whenever you
fine-tune you take actually the last
layer so that kind of gives you an idea
that the model is then it's sort of what
seems to be important is this coming up
with the higher level representation and
then once you fine tune you're probably
able to push that representation through
to the end because of your training
signal
but if you hadn't done the pre-training
you wouldn't even have that higher level
representation and then the signal I
guess is not strong enough to back
propagate through the whole model it
would be very interesting if they
investigate if they do this linear probe
analysis again after they fine-tune the
model that and to see if then still it
is the intermediate layers that have the
best representation or if now the best
representation in a linear probe sense
shifted towards the end I'm gonna guess
it's shifted towards the end but I sort
of want to even see if the accuracy of
the linear probe in the middle
does it keep the same right so does the
curve go like this this is the linear
probe when you simply pre-trained right
this is linear probe accuracy the
question would be does it change to be
like this or does it change to be like
this this is supposed to be the same at
the end so basically does it stay as
good as it is but simply get better at
the end or does the representation like
in this curve does the good
representation now shift towards the end
and leave the lower layer with even more
capacity to do some low level stuff yeah
maybe they've done this I haven't seen
it so and as you can see these Bert and
autoregressive object if they sort of
trade off so the birthda tends to do
poorly in the linear probe setting but
then it catches up during fine tuning in
C for 10 almost being at the level of
the autoregressive and in an image net
actually outperforming it this this
darker thing here it simply means that
you a ver across different maskings of
Bert because I guess even in
classification it's not entirely clear
how to get a signal out of Bert because
they don't do this CLS vector with Bert
what they do for classification and
linear probing and
it's written up here they simply take
the they do an average pooling I think
they do an average pooling of the of all
the representations of the sequence and
the last thing that I've also forgotten
there's a lot of stuff when they fine
tune while fine-tuning while fine-tuning
the classification loss yields
reasonable downstream performance we
find empirically that the joint
objective the generative objective and
the classification objective works even
better okay so even when you fine-tune
with this model you have to keep the
generative modeling part the generative
loss around and then it performs even
more better more well whatever that word
is so that's also something to think
about I think this this paper right here
it kind of lays down a lot of cool
things that you can think about and it
gives rise to a lot of hypotheses of how
does this stuff work why does this stuff
work I don't even think that the the
numbers are the most important thing
it's mostly the fact of the effects and
what does it mean okay so this was my
take on it it was it's more kind of a my
rant of what I find special about this
paper then about the actual paper you
can look at the paper their numbers are
pretty good on imagenet they do not
reach the same like SuperDuper
performance as they do on c 410 and i
guess that's probably because they have
to downscale the image net images way
more than they have to downscale to see
410 images because those are of course
only 32 by 32 so because they have to
downscale so much they lose probably a
lot of information and I would be
interested to see if there is a way to
involve convolution
in this in all of this so to do the
downscaling that in a learned manner
with convolutions or something I'm sure
this has all been done already I'm just
lazy to look it up yeah so I invite you
to look at their blog post where they
have these his samples they look pretty
pretty funny and these full samples up
here look fairly you know fairly cool
for what it's trained to do and that it
has no spatial awareness whatsoever it
simply uses learn position in coatings
and yeah check it out that was it for me
bye bye